do you think that like we've we've
had past lives and that we've
spiritually evolved to this point
or do you think like this is something
that we get one life and then
i mean come on dude that's that's a
rookie question of course we've
had thousands of lives but not a lot of
people think that yeah i don't know
i don't know if i believe that here's
the thing there's so much
irrefutable proof of reincarnation
that it's kind of laughable for anybody
to not
believe in it would you agree i love you
how sweet is that you're like no
this is proven you're like carl sagan
over there no we've got the
charts i mean obviously i do believe in
it and like i have a method
for understanding it just based on my
own like various incarnations in my own
life you know
like if you look back at all the phases
you've been through and you know every
single one you've gone through so many
[ __ ] faces for sure like i went
through like a like a
mild smith's face i was wearing like
[ __ ] you know what i mean but to me it
was real
that was almost like a different life or
like you know when i was in high school
certainly my concerns were so different
from now and also like my physical form
so when you look at like just the for
you forget like before
we're born and after we die if you just
look at the general human existence
there's so many lives in any human life
sure i mean
people are reincarnating all the [ __ ]
time right and so i think
that you know i whether or not this
there's some continuance i think there
is
i know it's not i i don't imagine it to
be provable i agree with what's the
proof you're talking about i mean just
like like the
people who particularly when they're
babies they'll just like say weird [ __ ]
and then they'll check it
and you know and yeah there's that like
four-year-old that like
yeah and predicted her past death and
they found the blazer
right like like little kids will be
looking at pictures and they'll be like
oh well that's when when i was doing
this and they're looking at the picture
like a dead grandfather and then
everything they say
checks out so yeah full disclosure i
mean i agree with you duncan i was just
trying to get the click bait
you know duncan talks about past lives
you know i mean
right actually look really you're like
the mocker valley of podcasters
that's awesome wow here's the problem
with uh reincarnation i think it's
it's it's a a great number of people are
tripped up over this
because of religion well no it's it's
there's a numbers
problem with it you know like if we are
reincarnated
then how do you how do you uh factor in
the ever-growing population ourselves
i solved it are some souls new or not
some souls recycled
and then yeah i think uh sure i think
that
when you factor in all the dimensions
that we're not privy to
and then when you factor in the fact
that even like a a
fleeting thought is is essentially a
life
you know like there is such
you guys are like kindred spirits dude
and then when you bring into it like the
crazy [ __ ] quantum
physics [ __ ] where it's like every
single possible
outcome of every single possible
situation is all simultaneously
happening and there is no such thing as
right now and all is right now like
then it gets really crazy and you don't
have to worry about the numbers game
anymore
then it works yeah yeah that is a that
is a valid
also um god man this is like
one of my one of the only times i really
broke through on dmt
at burning man i like did the thing and
went into the thing that everyone talks
about and i was in the [ __ ] thing and
you know but i had this
sense of like oh i could like completely
like obliviate myself here somehow merge
with the universe
obviously not true i don't never heard
of anyone dying on dmt but
that dmt not a voice but you know
whatever it is
said oh you can always go back you can
always go back to that moment if you
want
and then i ever since then i sort of
re-uh
revised my idea of reincarnation being a
thing that starts
with your birth and ends with your death
and and now i see
it more as like uh probably upon like
dropping your body or
as they call it in the east you might be
able to like actually choose
frames of your incarnation that you want
to jump back into
and start your life there meaning that
any given moment
like future versions of you are sort of
pouring into the current
version of you just to experience life
from this point going forward but you
would never know that because it's you
and they just
sort of resonate with you i mean i think
that the primitive idea of reincarnation
is that you die and you're you get a
break that's a funny one like a lot of
new agers have this spa
theory where you [ __ ] get hit by a
car and suddenly you're like floating in
like
some you know hyper dimensional spa
water like i think next
the next life i want to be paralyzed for
the neck down
that'll be awesome sure if it's really
the blueberry
i'm sorry i what it what if it it's not
like that what if it's just you die
and you open your eyes and you're like
in your 40s
going through a divorce there's no space
there's no rest
there's no anything and you you just
have a little deja vu
what the [ __ ] was that sure what
happened was you just came back in
into a new life full with full amnesia
of what you used to be
sure is a big deal and i have no problem
with any of that
i want to run by run by you two things
and then i want you to tell me if you
think uh i'm a genius or if this
is just completely idiotic but what if i
already think you're a genius
okay good i i i really think i've i kind
of figured something out with this
because the idea of like uh
how did it all begin it's just a stupid
question over there was big bang all
right well what banged
you know like okay then you come up with
something that banged all right well
where did that thing come from you know
you keep going back and like
so the concept of linear time is
clearly a flawed idea right and i
i've at one point i was smoking some pot
i was writing an email and i
i felt like i figured it out i said you
know there was a time
when humans thought the world was flat
and and they were actually terrified to
get in their boats and go too far
because they were legitimately scared
that their boat
would fall off the end of the world and
that they would perish
so then i just equated that i said you
know like
i believe we will come to a point where
it is seemingly
is equal equally ridiculous to think of
time as flat such that there's a
beginning or an end that you could fall
off of
when in fact just like the world
time is round dude you know it's a cycle
and uh i mean and if you think of it
that way then what was before that what
was before that was
nothing was before that because it's a
[ __ ] cycle it's round it doesn't
begin
or end and that's one that was one
little sort of thought that i had that i
was pretty proud of now i've got one
more
which is that the idea of of the body
and death now we've heard the saying
that we're not uh human beings having a
spiritual experience but rather we're
spiritual beings having a human
experience
now to give the the idea of like when we
die
we awaken to eternal life you know that
actually we're eternal
you know and and all of this um i
i like and especially because we're
multi-dimensional beings
so like like we absolutely exist in all
of these
we're just not aware of it because when
we incarnate in this physical body we
kind of make a deal
that we forget that we're spirits so we
don't know what the [ __ ] going on and
we certainly do wake up at the moment of
death
but now to look at death and and what it
really represents
the theory that i came up with was to
imagine that
that the soul so to speak is like
uh a [ __ ] uh
like a radio wave kind of a deal the
body
the body is essentially uh like a radio
that picks up
that uh you know now the the i think
that the flaw
in our view of the human brain is that
the
the human brain the human body is a
generator of consciousness you know like
a transmitter
it generates the consciousness like yeah
you know like uh
like said like a a transmitter would but
i don't see it that way i see the i see
the the human body the brain
as a receiver of the signal which is out
there
so now you to make it a metaphor you
could take a radio that's like dialed in
to like a certain station
like 106.7 right yeah now you can take
that [ __ ] physical radio
and you can take a sledgehammer to it
you can smash it you can
it you can destroy it destroy that body
until into oblivion
but you have done nothing to interrupt
or kill the signal so what we are is
that we're the
we're the the receiver of the signal
yeah you know where the receiver the
signal you can shoot yourself in the
head you can
all you're doing is killing the radio
you're not [ __ ] with the signal man
and the signal is forever dude and
and on top of that there's so many
stations dude there's
limit and you can plug that station into
a different [ __ ] radio later on down
the line and there's your reincarnation
and [ __ ]
yeah i love it yeah i thought about this
the receiver idea
it's particularly wrapped around like uh
you know when you meet someone who's all
puffed up and [ __ ]
and it's like uh
it's a quality of confusion i think you
know it's like a
if there were a sentient radio and it
was playing
the beatles it would be easy for the
radio to be like i'm [ __ ] amazed
totally yeah so i think people get a
little confused regarding their identity
uh in that regard i'll do that that's
another great layer on
top that just takes another step further
i [ __ ] love
that it's entanglement is what they call
it you know we're entangled in this
situation and um yeah and
like in buddhism it's uh this is sort of
the map of
how to sort of predict what your next
life is going to be
what they say is we'll look at what
you're doing now and that'll get you
give you some idea of where you're
headed
and it's because it's momentum based
essentially so it's like
whatever this particular frequency is it
has this kind of momentum to it the
momentum is karma
and so that momentum has been going on
for
you know millennia in calcul this was
actually one of my like
ketamine visions was i was seeing my
past lives
i couldn't specifically see him but i i
knew somehow like what i was looking at
was all my past lives
and there was so many of them and they
look like fish eggs kind of floating in
space just all these
ways my karma had expressed itself but
yeah it's like so this is why there is
this emphasis on meditation uh and
people get confused about the statement
meditation is the pr
you know preparation for death and what
what it means is like
there is an acknowledgement of exactly
what you're saying the body is
finite but there's this sort of
um transmission that is your soul
that's never going to stop and so when
you die it's
it's i mean just have you ever met like
a healthy i mean unless you're like
lucky and you just get hit you're like
jogging in a marathon get hit by a
[ __ ] car or something you know
probably you get sick when people are
dying they get really sick and confused
usually they're in a lot of pain then
they start taking the morphine
then they sort of like and you believe
you've seen someone die it's nuts
because they like
literally they lift off of that thing
you're talking about like
it's like watching an airplane take off
only it's taking off from the time from
time not you know not the earth and so
they
they're spiraling through like they're
they're talking to their mom
and then they're talking to like you
know somebody that they knew and they
you know you have no idea who they're
talking to but
it's because they're spiraling through
time because they're breaking free
but um you know but yeah but the uh
the momentum so so the idea here is like
you want to die
with some tranquility and some peace
because if you can't if you can handle
it which
some like some of these live tibetan
llamas they describe it as like being in
a snow storm
it's so confusing so if you can maintain
some
some element of being calm then there is
a possibility of
at the very least like having a little
bit more control
over what your next life might be
instead of it being like what it is for
what
what it what it is for a lot of people
which is like terrifying
and the description is like suddenly you
don't have a body you've had a body all
this [ __ ] time
and it's like what the [ __ ] i need a
body because that's what you're familiar
with
and then you you kind of you you
impatiently
race into your next into your parents
which by the way
which is something really cool in the
tibetan book of the dead which is what
they read to like
monks who've died to guide them into the
next life
you know the idea is you see all these
people [ __ ] not to go back to bang
bust or anything but it's like you
literally
see a field within which there's all
these people [ __ ]
and it's weirdly like i it's like porn
it's like
the one that turns you on the most you
you go to that
so basically you were watching your
parents [ __ ] and you're like that's
[ __ ] hot
i want to get in on that and you like go
into that and then the next thing you
know you're their kid
and this is the wow this is and this is
why in this life we're so into sex and
[ __ ] and all that because it's like
that
same momentum that brought us here you
know continues it's all momentum
it's really fascinating it's a really
fascinating take on what happens when
you die
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated
there's legal waivers all over the venue
because i'm actually worried about
getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and
it's all the stuff i wasn't allowed to
do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats